speaking of being divorced from the
truth Dylan Mulvaney it wouldn't be a
day that ends in why if Dylan Mulvaney
were not thrusting himself into the
headlines Dylan Mulvaney has accelerated
his activism and he now says
that we ought to arrest people who refer
to him as a man
articles written about me using he
pronouns and calling me a man over and
over again and I I feel like that should
be illegal I I don't know that's that's
just bad journalism I feel that should
be illegal don't you that we should
arrest people who don't think that I'm a
beautiful stunning woman
I'm just a picture of Grace and
femininity I Dylan Mulvaney we should
arrest those people
we went from
just leave us alone how does this affect
you what's your problem why are you so
obsessed with us to call me a beautiful
lady or you're going to prison
in
like six months that was pretty fast
wasn't it
Dylan Mulvaney's only been pretending to
be a woman for slightly over one year
he's on his 368th day or something like
that of pretending to be a woman and we
went from tihihi isn't this so silly I'm
a lady
how does this affect you too you're
going to the gulag if if you don't call
me she actually sir it's ma'am it's it's
that video of the giant guy in the
bodega
that guy is more Peaceable and amiable
than Dylan Mulvaney
Dylan Mulvaney doesn't yell and scream
but the threat is far more serious
this is what
they want why
why are they so insistent
because public lies
require ever more Force to prop them up
if you're telling the truth and you're
orienting your Society according to the
truth you don't need nearly as much
force because the truths on which you
base your Society are clear to people
people can perceive them they can deduce
them using their reason they can Intuit
them using their moral conscience
if however you're grounding your Society
on absurdities then those absurdities
are not clear to people
in fact it's it's quite clear that
they're false and so to establish them
in society you need Force to tell people
don't believe your eyes don't use your
faculties of Reason deny your moral
conscience
shut up or we're throwing you in the
gulag
that's why
that's why at times in our Nations and
civilizations history when Society has
been more normal and in line with
reality the government has had a lighter
touch
the government can afford a lighter
touch but as Society becomes more absurd
the government has to become more
tyrannical the government has to become
totalitarian
because any little crack in the artifice
that has been built up can threaten the
whole system so if you're living
according to Communism say which is
based on false ideas about human nature
and reality then you can't allow
you can't allow a representative of the
people to speak up in Congress or the
parliament certainly not but you can't
even allow a novelist to question it you
can't even allow Pro families to
question it around the dinner table you
certainly can't allow TV shows to
question these sorts of things because
any little crack
will be persuasive to people
because people
can know something about the truth they
can recognize the truth
Sometimes using their reason using their
moral conscience
don't don't think this is Dylan Mulvaney
Jumping the Shark he's not this is the
inevitable consequence of establishing a
lie so absurdist transgenderism in our
law and culture right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code Knowles we
all know about the big wireless cell
companies out there they lock you into
these horrendous contracts if you try to
get out of them early they tack on
outrageous charges that is why I'm so
pleased to use Pure Talk Wireless where
there are no hidden fees no contracts no
hassle pure talks U.S customer service
team made it incredibly easy to sign up
you can keep your old phone number if
you want Pure Talk has a range of
affordable cell phone plans to choose
from you can find the perfect option for
your needs such as unlimited talk text
and plenty of data for just thirty
dollars a month their 5G service is fast
consistent doesn't drop your calls you
get the same coverage when I say the
same I don't mean similar I mean the
same coverage that you are used to at
half the rate you're currently paying
puretalk saves the average family over
nine hundred dollars per year not only
will you save more money you will also
get the satisfaction of knowing you're
supporting a great American company the
CEO and chairman of pure talk is a U.S
military vet when you become a Pure Talk
customer you're given the option to
support America's Warrior partnership
which works to prevent veteran suicide
go to puretalk.com enter promo code
Knowles save 50 off your first month
five zero percent that is puretalk.com
promo code knows Pure Talk is simply
smarter Wireless speaking of
irrationality North Carolina man
was critically injured he almost died
when his neighbor
allegedly started shooting him and his
poor little girl and some other children
why did the Neighbors start shooting the
children and then the father why did he
try to murder the little kids because
their ball rolled into his yard
these little children were playing with
a ball and the ball rolled into his yard
so he got a gun and tried to murder the
children why did he do it well he yelled
I don't even like white people
his name is Robert Lewis Singletary he's
24 years old turned himself into
authorities after he was on the lamb for
a couple of days and realized he was
going to get caught so he goes he turns
himself in he fired at this poor little
girl and her parents white and Ashley
Hildebrand
after after the ball rolled onto the
property said you white I don't even
like white people I'm going to shoot
your AWS and then according to the
father he fires three shots he hasn't
hit anybody yet so I turn around and
look my daughter's right in front of me
I look and see he's pointing straight at
my daughter so this father just jumps
and he gets shot and is critically
injured uh the daughter caught shrapnel
in her cheek but luckily
luckily they they seem to have lived
you almost certainly haven't heard about
the story anywhere maybe on some
conservative Channel but this sort of
thing is suppressed obviously goes
without saying if the if the races were
reversed then this would be a national
news story the president would give a
speech about it there would be a
national conversation going on there
might be riots but in this case it's not
we just sort of ignore it we ignore the
fact that he shot these people because
they're white
this is
the real American Constitution lowercase
C Constitution we have an uppercase C
Constitution that's written on parchment
and that uppercase C constitution
written on parchment
is related to other founding documents
The Federalist Papers the Declaration of
Independence
and so we have this view of how American
society Works based on Schoolhouse Rock
You know I'm a bill up on Capitol Hill
but that's not the real Constitution
according to the real Constitution
there are favored groups and disfavored
groups
and if you're a member of a favored
group you will be treated differently by
the law and by the culture and if you're
a member of a disfavored group
and that's what we're seeing playing out
now and some of those are sometimes in
flocks women for instance are more
favored than men
but they are less favored than men who
think that they're women and so so if
women women can claim discrimination by
men and the law will look favorably upon
them but women can't claim
discrimination by so-called trans women
the men who think that they're women the
law will look more favorably on the
transgenderist people
obviously according to the law into the
culture white people are pretty much the
only group that you can discriminate
against and insult and non-white people
can do no wrong they're the greatest
people on Earth every problem is because
of whiteness every solution will be by
turning away from whiteness the original
sin of our civilization these are ideas
that are not only floating around the
culture but are articulated explicitly
by the people who wield power in the
culture and so
a a presidential candidate as we look
ahead to 2024 a presidential candidate
who
is successful
is going to have to speak to the real
lowercase C Constitution not just on
this issue of you know black people good
white people bad that our popular
culture puts out
oh yes this guy shot a little tried to
shoot a little girl and I guess
ultimately did because of the shrapnel
in her cheek because she's white
oh yeah okay never mind Move Along move
along but not just that it's the whole
issue of how does our society really
work put aside the transgender issues
and the race issues and all those other
issues how does our society really work
who wields the power how do we bring
those powerful forces back into line how
do we reign in the media the New York
Times the state paper
from from
basically just pushing State propaganda
how do we fix that how do we how do we
tweak the education system all the rest
of it a real successful presidential
candidate I don't want to hear
platitudes about the Fourth of July and
the Declaration of Independence I want
people to address the actual
Constitution According to which the
unwritten Constitution According to
which society operates today boy was
that good it was really excellent
incisive handsome commentary if you want
more of it you got to ring the bell and
click the thing and do the doodad And
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel
see you next time
[Music]